- [Gary] Thank you guys so much.
Super pumped to be here.
Quick little six
hour flight, this keynote,
and take a red-eye
home tonight, so hustling.
Look, I think there's a
lot that I want to cover.
I see the mics here, so
I definitely wanna do some Q&amp;A
during this talk as well.
I've been getting some context
to the audience makeup.
And so obviously a
very entrepreneurial crowd.
There's a lot going on.
It seems like a good amount of
you have some context for me.
I'm sure some of you don't.
But what I really
wanna speak about
is really just the
current state of things.
The thing that I think will
index for anybody in this room
whether today's your first day
or you've been in it for awhile.
Whether you're in
a B to B environment,
a B to C environment, trying
to build your personal brand,
trying to sell homes,
trying to start an app.
Whatever it may be,
I wanna really kind of go
on the things that
I see that are happening
that will bring the most value
and that I think through
Q&amp;A we'll go into the stuff
that brings
more individual value
and I encourage
you to be selfish
when you get up here
and ask your questions.
I think the place to
start with a healthy mix here
of young faces and
some that are not as young,
along with my face that is not
as young, is the following,
which is for the
20-year-old crowd in here,
the early 30-year-old crowd,
there's a lack of
context of realizing how special
the environment we are in is,
because it's the only
one you've ever known.
This is what
you've grown up with.
You've grown up
in this environment.
with the internet
and there's a lack
of understanding of how
ridiculously big this is.
On the other hand, the people
that have been successful
for 10, 15, 20, 30 years,
there's an understanding
that all this new
stuff is different,
but there is the cliche
fear and curiosity
versus the tried and true
that is super interesting.
And so for me, the thing that
I wanna really drill home
in my opening
statements is the following.
I really need this
audience to understand
that we are
obnoxiously fortunate
to be in this position
right this minute,
because actually this is fun
because I know there's a
lot of real estate DNA here.
I genuinely view
what's happening
on the internet right now
similar to when
some of the great cities,
somebody bought up
New York for fucking nothing.
And when I mean
nothing I mean dollars.
Not millions or a hundred,
there was a human beings
who actually bought,
and I don't even know,
this is where I wish I'd done
a little bit better in school,
but the Louisiana Purchase
was a fucking steal.
(audience laughter)
And I actually
genuinely think that
that's what's happening
on the internet right now.
Now I think it's ten years in.
The consumer internet
that I'm passionate about
is really only 20 years old.
It was really Windows 95
that got normal people
to figure out how to
get onto the internet.
It was AOL, right,
it's really only 20 years.
But the Web 2.0 in
to social media internet
is really only a decade old.
And I think everybody here now,
whether it's the
presidential election,
or Brexit, or the Arab Spring,
or something that happened
in your family
amongst eight people,
I think everybody realizes now,
unlike a decade ago when
I was talking about this,
that this is big shit.
That this is not some little
cable TV extension of main TV,
this is not some
fad that's gonna be
around for a little bit.
This is the fundamental shift
of how human beings
interact with each other
which is the
currency of our lives.
And so I guess the thing
that I'm trying to frame up
for a lot of you right now is
I don't think this room,
including myself,
actually understands how
big of an opportunity this is,
in whatever you care about.
You sit in this
room as I do today
caring about business
aspects of your life.
But this goes far beyond that.
I mean, we're in a world
now where just ten years ago
if you did online dating
you were weird and awkward
and lived in your mom's basement
and now it's the
only way people do it.
We need to understand
how big this really is
because when you
start understanding
that this is oxygen,
that this is oxygen!
That this, in it's current form,
and soon contact lenses when
everything is virtual reality
or AR or AI or wherever it goes,
that this is our currency.
Literally so many of you
would struggle to function
without your
cellphone by your side.
You would not realize the detox
that you would
actually go through
if you didn't have your phone.
You run to the Apple Store,
run to the Apple Store,
when you lose or
break your phone.
You cry for the four hour
delay that you have to wait.
(audience laughter)
And by the way,
many of you are gonna sit
as I say this right
now, and think it's sad.
I don't, I think it's evolution.
I don't think it's sad.
I really don't.
I think it's a thing.
I think it's the thing.
I think people thought
a lot of things were sad.
Like the television and
the telephone and the car.
People thought
things were sad always
when it wasn't what
they grew up with. Right?
There's people that
always think it's not important
until it becomes mainstream.
I'm 41 and grew
up on the East Coast.
Hip hop wasn't
supposed to be a real thing.
It is the main currency now.
This is what always
happens with humans
and so I tell you all of this
because I can get
into the details of
what do you do on
direct message on Instagram,
or what does it take with work
life balance and work ethic
and how do you do Facebook ads
and all the cliche shit that
I know you're gonna ask me,
(audience laughter)
but before,
but before we get into that
I really want to get every,
I feel like the one
thing I can do for everybody,
if you leave here and realize
that this is all
just the beginning,
that it's never going back,
that it's way
bigger than you think,
I mean I have people
emailing me every day
selling $8 million homes
from one Facebook ad.
This is real.
We're here!
This is not coming, this is
not your 14-year-old daughter,
this is now.
This is happening right now.
If there're people in this room
that haven't fully committed
to being relevant
in the mobile device
for their business.
They're basically not relevant.
They're trading on the
history of what got them here.
You're trading
on the word of mouth
of the people that you've done
business with in the past,
but that dwindles everyday.
And if you have any interest,
how many people in this room
are actually retiring
in the next five years,
and I don't mean
you're gonna fucking crush it
and buy an island.
(audience laughter)
I mean you're just
fucking old and you're finished.
(audience laughter)
How many people, five years?
Raise your hands.
Love it, five.
Got one, two, great.
For you, it's an
interesting debate, right?
Can you hold on
to what got you here
for the next five,
kinda hold onto it?
You'll be diminishing
returns of attention
and things of that nature.
There'll be other young upstarts
that activate
against the opportunities,
but for five years, even
though that's a long time,
I actually think
all of the stuff that
I believe in the most,
you could
probably hold on, right?
For everybody else,
this is binary.
You're basically in
the same position right now
that every person that owned
a bunch of taxi medallions
and black car services did
the day before Uber started.
For everybody else in this room
except for those
two lovely people,
who by the way both
look pretty fucking good,
and I'm not so sold on
completely done in five,
(audience laughter)
For everybody else,
you're basically
the owner of four very
good bookstores in your town
the day before Amazon
decided to get serious.
Your entire life,
regardless of industry,
over the next decade,
will be eaten up by technology.
And either you're
on the eating side,
or you're on the other side.
And I don't think
most people here
wanna get shitted out, right?
(audience laughter)
- Right?
And so for me, for me,
this is not fun games.
This is like really important,
because you have to understand,
regardless of what you
do in this room, regardless,
there's only one
thing I'm sure of,
we all trade on the same
currency, and that is attention.
Attention is the number
one currency in our society.
Before you tell me how
great you are at what you do,
or how great your
service is, or what you do,
or how nice
your fucking dressed,
'cause this crew rolls that way.
(audience laughter)
Before you do that,
you need my attention to even
be able to tell me that.
And if you don't
have it, you fucking lost.
And the attention of
our society is right here.
And you may think it's sad,
and you may not like it,
but it's the punch line.
And the romance of
how you want it to be,
or how it used to be,
is fucking irrelevant.
This is reality.
So now, I say to myself,
if we all agree
that this is it, right?
That this it the dominant
place for the attention of
our consumers, well
then you gotta start looking
at social media
super differently
'cause social media,
my friends, takes up
50% of every
human being's time on this.
And now all of a sudden
it's not just a nice to have,
or this emerging kind of thing,
or kind of cute.
Now all of a sudden,
it's the Yellow Pages,
and the billboards,
and the bus stop ad,
and the direct mail,
and the local commercial,
and the TV show, if
you're lucky to be one of
those four realtors,
and all of it in one place.
And here's where it gets crazy,
there's no gatekeepers.
There's nobody between you
and the person you're trying
to reach on this platform,
except the platforms itself.
Which is why Facebook's
such a big company, got it?
And so this is a mindset shift,
I recognize that
20 to 80% of this room is
not pot-committed
to this environment.
Even the most
committed young players,
and when I say young, just
real quick, young mentality.
It's not an age thing,
there's a bunch of 27-year-olds
running around like it's 1942.
(audience laughter)
And there's a bunch of
61 year olds that fucking
try everything and
they're fucking pot-committed.
This is a mentality,
so 20 to 80% of the people in
this room, like, to me,
they're just not pot committed.
And for me, when
I know somethings happening,
Google in their early days,
which built Wine Library.
Facebook and Instagram
influencers right now,
you know, I'm not a poker
player, but I do know this,
if you have the best hand,
it's a good idea to go all-in.
And so we have a
little window here.
I've been doing my thing
for 20 years, not forever,
but long enough to know this:
I've only seen it twice,
2001 to 2003 Google, which oh
by the way, Amazon and eBay
built their entire businesses
on the back of Google.
Under priced attention.
Everything still works,
somebody raised their hand,
got in line, "Gary I do
direct mail, and it works".
Mazel Tov, Rick.
(audience laughter)
I know that it can still work,
I just also know that
you can do
Facebook ads as direct mail
and convert four times more.
So you spent $10,000 for X,
and I can spend
$10,000 for four X's.
It's not about what
doesn't work or works anymore,
it's what's under priced
and what's over priced.
Television commercials can
work, it's just not fun to spend
a million dollars on
them today, compared to 1974
when we didn't
have remote controls,
and actually
fucking watched them.
(audience laughter)
- So, this is what I think
about, this is what I trade on,
and we all know it's
going only in one direction.
The number one job dream,
of every 13 to
16 year old in America
is to be a Youtuber
and or an influencer.
That this literally what they
want to be in their lives.
This is now over.
That's it.
The amount of people that
don't have cable, is staggering.
will never get to page 106
in a magazine to see
your ad, is staggering.
Your car's gonna drive
anywhere you want to go for you,
it's happening now.
This isn't coming.
Get a new Tesla,
shit does all of it.
Like, this is real.
And so, what I don't think
people know, and why I brought
up the five year question, is:
if you think
back to 10 years ago,
we're just
getting the first iPhone.
Yeah.
Guys, 10 years ago,
none of this shit existed.
YouTube and Facebook are babies,
and are like for
very small niches.
We don't have smartphones yet.
Like, where do you
think this is going?
So what I'm fearful of,
is while you sit and debate,
if you should be doing Facebook,
or Instagram influencers,
or Snapchat, or have
a blog, or start a vlog,
or do a podcast.
While you sit and
debate this minor leagues shit,
which is right
now the major leagues,
the majors are coming, what
are you gonna do about
Alexa Skills when
people are like,
"Alexa, I wanna
go to open houses",
and Alexa tells you which
open houses you're going to.
And if you're not
playing there, where are you?
Right?
Like where are you?
Because what I'm
most worried about,
is I'm worried about
all of your digital DNA.
If you're pushing
up against this shit,
you're really gonna get
ran over in the next decade.
You'll never be
good at augmented reality
if you weren't good at Facebook.
(audience laughter)
I mean, right?
I mean, how are
you ever gonna be ready
for the next shit if
you're still fighting this
and super pumped
to spend your money
on a fucking bench ad?
(audience laughter and applause)
So,
I guess where my
energy is clearly going,
since I never know what the
fuck I'm gonna talk about,
(audience laughter)
is I think the stakes
are higher than you think.
And I think that, when
you wake up in two years
and see that Ralph Lauren Polo
has gone out of business,
and when you wake up
in two or three
years and see that
Gamestop is out of business,
like when you start seeing it,
and you're seeing it, right?
And you can feel it.
I mean, any of you.
Have you been to a mall lately?
Shit is sad.
(audience laughter)
Right?
And what does happen?
There's a lot of
youngsters in here,
let me go into a 15
year innovation talk.
What does happen when
we have self-driving cars
and we actually
enjoy our commutes,
and all of a sudden,
prime real estate
is not as prime
as it used to be,
because all of a sudden,
now a 15 minute commute
when you can do
everything in it,
all of a sudden
becomes a more interesting
thing for humans to do.
You guys know macro trends,
the cities in this
country over the last 30 years
were dead and they
resurged over the last decade
because the youth
is more interested
in living in the cities because
the dynamics have changed.
What happens when
people actually figure out
it's not a good
idea to own a home?
'Cause the math is
super intriguing,
and the game's changing.
And so, I really
wanna push everybody
to understand
this is big stakes.
This isn't,
"How am I gonna build
"my personal brand
on Instagram, Gary?"
I don't give a fuck, Ralph.
(audience laugher and applause)
This is,
do you actually
understand the era
that you're living through?
This is the
Industrial Revolution.
This is like
getting electricity.
This is big shit.
And this is big shit not only
in your business life, but in
the dynamics of who we are.
All this stuff going on,
wherever you are on politics,
this is not him or her.
This is the dynamics
of media in our society.
This is dynamics of all
of us having media 24/7.
This is what's happening.
We're about to change.
And so, bringing it back
to the micro of business,
that means a lot of
money is about to be made,
and a lot of
money's about to be lost.
And what I haven't
figured out is
how many of you are willing
to draw a line in the sand
and say that you hate
all this technology stuff
and aren't will to
put in the 20 hours
to read and watch
videos to educate yourself
out of your raw emotion,
when it's gonna wipe you out.
And I think that's awesome.
I think you deserve to
go directly out of business
if you're not
willing to put in the work.
(audience laugher)
I do.
(audience applause)
If you're wrong about
what's about to happen
and you weren't
willing to put in the work,
you deserve to lose.
And so that's
what's gonna happen.
And so I would say this.
Please, please understand
that this is the beginning.
We are definitely,
definitely going to live,
at this point in my opinion,
in an augmented reality world.
Which means what
you see happening
with Snapchat and Instagram
where you have your
face and then puppies
and fuckin Coachella
things and all that stuff,
that's about to go super far.
You're all going
to wear contact lenses
in 20 years
where you're
seeing the real world,
an augmented world,
and a virtual world
on an everyday basis, blended.
Always, and forever.
That's what's coming.
And so look.
I'm just as pissed
as everybody else.
(audience laughter)
And I'm not looking forward
to the robots killing all of us.
(audience laughter)
But they're gonna win.
And so we might as
well enjoy our time now.
(audience laughter)
And I'd like you to
be on the side of it
instead of against it.
I'm not super special.
The reason I'm gonna
win at the highest levels
is I don't fight reality.
- [Man] That's brutal.
- I'm brutal in my
complete lack of romance
of how it should be
and my complete investment
into how it actually is.
Right?
(audience applause)
Guys, do you
know how pissed I was
that social media came along?
I had digital media figured out.
I was winning on
email and Google AdWords.
Like, I'd won.
Like, it was devastating.
I was like,
"Fuck, this is gonna work."
You know?
And by the way,
you're gonna see it.
You'll watch 53-year-old me,
completely be
obsessed with VR, AR, AI,
or whatever else is
about to be invented,
I have no idea
that I'm gonna believe
your attention will be.
And you're all
gonna actually see it.
The first time,
nobody knew who I was.
This time, I'm so
associated with this stuff,
when you see me in seven years
and whatever the
Facebook feed of the day is,
and the video's gonna be like,
"You're still doing Facebook,
you fucking asshole?"
(audience laughter)
And you're gonna be like,
"What? Isn't that
what he believes in?"
No, I believe in
trading attention
in the day that
we actually live in.
I believe making my
actions allow me to sell
what I wanna sell.
And when I say sell,
I mean selling a home,
a pair of sneakers,
or raising awareness
for Crohn's disease
because my brother, AJ, has it.
Or raising money for
the PTA or whatever may be.
Selling or bringing awareness
to whatever matters to
me, and as we all know,
what matters to
you today was different
than five years ago,
and in five years,
it's gonna be different again.
And that's just the way it is.
And so I implore you,
and I see a line
starting to gather,
so if you wanna
start gathering in line,
'cause I don't think
I'll get to all of them,
it's a good
time to start moving.
I implore you
to understand, yes,
I believe in social media.
B, I think that's a slang term
for the current
state of the internet.
You know people call YouTube
and LinkedIn social media sites,
they are not.
As a matter of fact,
there's only one
social media site left.
It's called Twitter.
All the other ones
are just content push.
There's no back-and-forth really
in a lot of places anymore.
So that's just the word.
Don't get hung up on it.
Everything you see
that's happening with me
is 'cause I'm trading attention.
I believe in sound,
I think every person here
needs to wrap their head around
the following statement,
which is this:
You are a media company first,
and then whatever
else you do for a living.
You have to start understanding
that you're a media company.
Now, that may mean,
and for a lot of you,
it means that that's you, you.
For others, it doesn't
have to be you, right?
The Huffington Post
wasn't Ariana Huffington
and every post, like,
you could be the platform.
But you better realize
you're in the media business.
Because the cost of
being in the media business
is now zero in
distribution opportunity,
in production, it's so low.
It's so low.
DRock and I did
an episode of DailyVee,
our vlog, that came out today,
my latest vlog,
right now, on YouTube
was all filmed on this.
You know?
So I don't wanna
hear your bullshit excuses
that you don't have a fucking
camera, or the lighting.
Everybody's in the
fucking excuse business.
Every one of you's
running through your head
right now of why you're
not in the media business
or why you're not doing
this, and it's all bullshit.
It's because you
have decided not to.
It's binary.
This is simple.
Either you're in it,
or your not.
'Cause once you make
the mental decision
that you're in it, maybe
you invest in a nice camera
instead of another fucking suit.
(audience laughter)
(audience applause)
I think it's on.
How are you?
Do you guys
have to turn this on?
Let's see what happens.
- [Rich] There we go.
- There we go, awesome.
- [Rich] Hey Gary,
I'm Rich from Austin.
Number one, I'm a
retired attack helicopter pilot
for the Marines and
I brought a patch for you.
For you and DRock,
can I bring you this to you?
(audience applause)
- Thank you.
Thanks for your
service, brother.
Thank you.
Thanks so much.
- [Rich] I'll tell you
the story about this one day.
- Okay.
- [Rich] Alright, so real
quick, I know there's a line.
So I work full-time.
I don't have time to
do what I want to do yet.
My plan is this.
Another pilot and
I want to get together,
we want to go around
to successful veterans
in all types of
industries that we know
and interview them for free.
Alright, I don't
need your fucking money.
I don't need anything.
I want to show veterans
who are gonna transition,
'cause it's
incredibly difficult.
And there's another
problem, there's also
a group of veterans that think
they're entitled
to shit, alright?
- Yep, that's right.
- [Rich] And we need to
dispel both those rumors.
- I think that's right.
- So, what I wanna
do is go interview
and just paint
the picture, like hey,
here's what you can be.
The only thing that's
not allowing me to execute
and I'm
overanalyzing, Danny, for sure,
is that I want
them to be authentic.
- Take the risk.
Everybody's scared to waste time
when time is your
number one asset that you have.
So go interview Charles, and
then three fourths of the way
you're like, fuck,
this guy's so full of shit
and don't show it.
(audience laughter)
(audience applause)
That's right.
- [Rich] So what I mean is,
I guess part of the vulgarity
is authenticity is
what attracted me to you.
I was like holy shit.
I've never seen a guy like this.
And I don't want them to
hide behind whatever logo
they work for or whatever.
- Yeah.
- [Rich] And them not
to see the real picture.
I want them to know, hey
there's still that guy or gal
in uniform there, right there.
- Yeah.
- [Rich] You know what I mean?
So I'm not sure--
- How about financially?
Can you do it now?
Because there's,
I have a really good idea.
That's why I'm asking.
- [Rich] I collect
retirement, so that's good.
And then my
full-time job is great.
I would have limited time
but my partner and I wanna go
probably three or
four interviews a month.
Just fly out to wherever and
then do what we gotta do.
- Great. So I mean, A,
your ability to get a sponsor
for this is very high.
Like most businesses
can't get a sponsor on spec,
but because of
the subject matter,
literally if you just
called emailed the top 1000
corporations in America,
you'd probably make so much
sponsorship money
you'd be like fuck.
Anyway, (audience laughter)
I think, I mean I don't think
that's valid, what you said.
- [Rich] Okay.
- Just go do the interview.
Do your best.
Like, maybe get an
extra sponsor to hire somebody
to vet people so
they can really vet.
But like that's not scary.
Because, then you
just don't have to show it.
You don't suck the fly somewhere
and it didn't work out,
but you can hire an
intern or a $38,000 a year
employee who could do
ridiculous research on anybody
to get you to
third and a half base
and then you watch
something for ten minutes
and make a gut decision.
- [Rich] Thank you so much.
- You're welcome.
(audience applause)
How are you?
- [Man] So you did a
video on sales versus marketing.
- Yes.
- [Man] About a month ago.
- [Man] So my question
to you, and you alluded
to it earlier when
you said what happens if
people said they don't
wanna buy a house anymore.
I'm in direct sales.
I've been in direct
sales for seven years
and I know a lot of
people in this room are.
My question is
where in the future,
say five to ten years
in the future from now,
where are you
pushing your chips?
Are you pushing it
into sales and sales,
or are you
pushing it into marketing?
The reason I'm asking is with
Amazon and your boy Jeff Bezos
and Tesla, they
don't do tons and tons of,
they don't spend tons and
tons of money on marketing
or on advertising.
I don't think. I don't know.
- They do.
- [Man] They do? 'Kay.
So, my question I guess is--
- They both work.
- [Man] They both work?
They're the two foundations
of how shit gets done.
You either
retarget people, affiliate,
all the tactical
shit that sells something
or, what is much
more interesting,
which is people don't
even realize why they bought
the shit they're
wearing right now,
because they were marketed to.
Marketing and branding
is just grown-up sales.
- [Man] So in the future,
when people are able
to buy anything they
want to and just go through
an experience on their phone.
- Yes.
- [Man] Right?
Does that cut out the
direct sales portion of it?
- Of course it could.
- [Man] Okay so, where
are you putting your money
in five to ten years
for the car industry,
the home industry.
- Right, I mean I think, look,
I think what the internet
does and technology does
is it squeezes
the middle man out
because the
Internet is the middle man.
And so, yeah I mean
I think I'm putting my money
on whoever's making
shit because they're going
to be able to at
a much higher level
do the sales and
marketing themselves
and not be at the
mercy of the middle.
However, that market will
always exist 'cause guess what?
A lot of people are
good at sales and marketing.
Right? So there's, I wouldn't
worry, you're a young dude,
I wouldn't worry,
your sales skills
translates forever.
100%.
- [Man] I just started
the business since when--
- But I would say that
make sure you don't become
too transactional because that's
when you become
your most vulnerable.
- [Man] Got it.
Cool, thanks.
- Yeah.
(audience applause)
- [Danny] Gary Vee!
What's up?
- Life is good, my man.
- [Danny] Hey Gary,
what's going on?
Danny Gold
selling Silicon Valley.
That's my DRock
right here, Dusty.
So I have a YouTube channel
right now, Facebook channel.
Really right now
I'm doing a lot of
just daily vlogs, right,
and so you talk
about reverse engineering
and bringing value,
disproportionate value
to those that
you're trying to market to,
as opposed to what
you expect in return.
- Yep.
- [Danny] Right now, my
business is doing really well.
My real estate business, right?
But I'm looking
at this vlog thing
as more of a long term,
personal brand,
celebrity type
of endeavor, right?
So then, I understand
how to bring value
to my community per se, but
then how as a daily vlogger
do I actually
bring value to people
that I don't even know?
- Right. Or that are not
in real estate, right?
- [Danny] Or that
are not in real estate
or have no
interest in real estate.
- I think you've only got one
move to really be successful
which is to not
pander to the camera
and to live your true life
and see if people give a fuck.
(audience applause)
That's the way to answer, right?
Because either
they are or they aren't.
But the thing that you
need to trade on is your truth
because that's the
thing that's scalable
because it's always there.
You know how fun
it is for me to always
just always have to be me?
It's super exhausting
to try to not be yourself
and it doesn't scale
and people taste it.
So the reason
reality TV worked was it was
a little further than acting.
But it's still full
of shit which is why
vlogging's better
than reality TV.
And so, and I think the thing,
people that you see pop
are really in their zone.
They're not trying to
become a celebrity per se,
they want what
celebrity brings which is,
celebrity is the number
one arbitrage in our society.
Like it is the number
one arbitrage in our society
it's leverage.
At scale.
But I think when
people try to pander to it,
it comes off.
So my biggest advice for you man
is to just live
your actual life.
I think the biggest
problem for the modern,
young male entrepreneur,
vlogger personality
is they're
fronting to a lifestyle
that isn't always
true to the reality
of what they're living
and then it just
gets convoluted, right?
- [Danny] Right.
- You know like,
people are already starting
to get called out for
like making pretend they're
taking private
flights but they're not.
(audience laughter)
So I would give you a
really good piece of advice
from somebody who
I think really knows what he's
talking about, just live it.
Just live your fucking life.
Like that's,
you'll do much better.
(audience applause)
- [Danny] Sweet, thank you.
- Take care Dusty.
(audience laughter)
- [Man 2] Holy shit,
this is a dream,
first I just wanted
to take this opportunity
to say thank you from
the bottom of my heart
and just express
my deepest gratitude
for all the content you put out
and just since
I started listening to you
a couple months ago
just how big of an impact
you've made not
only in my business
but my life, I think
everyone here can attest to that
and I just want to give
you a huge round of applause
for that.
(audience applause)
One thing that I've
really been paying attention
to you with lately is
about "Don't listen to what
"I say, watch what I do."
- Yeah.
- [Man 2] And so for me,
in business what I'm
trying to do right now
is just really scale
and build a great culture,
and build a great team.
- [Gary] Awesome.
- [Man 2] So I want to know,
what do I need to do to earn
the opportunity to
fly out to VaynerMedia
for the day and
just be a fly on the wall
and shadow you,
because I just want to learn
and I just want it so bad.
And I'm willing to
do whatever it takes.
- Done.
- [Man 2] Fuck.
(audience applause and cheers)
Thank you, thank you.
- [Mike] How's it going Gary?
- Right, you don't
get if you don't ask.
(audience laughter)
- [Mike] My name's Mike,
that was pretty freaking awesome
what you just did for that guy.
You probably
gonna change his life.
So I'm a real
estate agent with Interal,
I just want to know what's--
(audience cheering)
- [Gary] Probably my
favorite thing about the real
estate industry is
the team dynamics, right?
(audience laughter)
- [Mike] So what's
the future for real
estate agent, you
think we're gonna be taken out?
- I don't think so.
- [Mike] You don't think so?
- Humans are not going anywhere
until the robots kill us.
(audience laughter)
So I think,
so here's how I think about it.
I think there's a
tidal wave of technology coming,
I framed that up right?
But I don't think
it wipes out humans,
I think it wipes
out humans that decide
not to get their
surfboard and jump on it.
So I think what's gonna happen
to real estate agents is,
first of all, the
real estate industry
is fascinating,
because it reminds me
you know the tech
industry, the startup tech
world now reminds
me a lot of real estate
now that I've been in it,
because the real
estate industry has cycles
when it's so
good that losers win.
(audience laughter)
(audience applause)
It's true, it's just true.
And so, but it's not
just the real estate industry,
Wall Street has that,
the tech industry has it,
but it is extreme in real estate
because the crashes are extreme.
- [Mike] Right.
- Right?
So I think I would
tell you far more scary
to me than what's
happening with technology
in real estate, is
people's blind belief
that it's always
going to be good and they
over leverage themselves.
I'm just so fascinated by,
and when I say over leverage,
there's people who
buy up stuff and you're
overleveraged and you have debt,
and then there's
just people that are just
selling and making commissions,
but they're over
leveraging themselves
in the way they're
treating their lifestyle.
Like they think it's a good idea
to buy shit and not save money
as if the market
will always be good
and then when
the market's not good
then it's not good.
(audience laughter)
So I think
real estate is fine,
I don't think there's any major
stuff happening
other than I think that
the people in this
room that use the new
technologies to build
their firm or personal
brand within it are
going to disproportionately
outshine people.
And the people
I'm most worried about
are the people that
have very good reputations
in their market,
because that's
always been consistent
for the last 100 years,
that you can trade
on your reputation
and word of mouth,
and I think they don't
realize that the word
of mouth is about shift to
only the digital environment,
and so like literally
there's not even going to be
an opportunity for
people to like give you the word
of mouth cause they're
going to be endorsing people
with a share on Facebook
instead of giving your name
out at a barbecue, and
it's gonna happen faster
than people think,
so that's my fear.
It's the people
that have tried and true
reputations in
their market and have seen
generations before
them trade on that,
and they got caught
because they're in this moment
and six years from
now there's gonna be seven
upstarts not one,
that is going to take the
market from them.
- [Mike]
Appreciate it Gary, really
quickly, what's your
favorite Logic 301 song?
(Gary laughs)
He's my favorite
artist, that's why.
- Bobby Tarantino?
I think
you know what's interesting,
before I...I'm thinking
about the new album that
he just dropped,
let me go a
different route with you.
You know what I
really like about him?
Is why he won.
And what I'm
trying to get across here.
Bobby, and Russ,
and Kyle and all these
characters are
winning, and they're
gonna be the
biggest hip hop artists
in the world on
everything I've been talking
about for the last 20 minutes.
Got it?
That's the game.
(audience applause)
- [Man 3] Wow, what's up Gary?
- What's up, man?
- [Man 3] So I'm 23
years old, entrepreneur,
I believe it's in my
DNA and you've really
made me question that,
so the reason why I wanted
to ask you this question
been kinda holding out,
every one of us
in this room has to
battle mental strength.
- Sure.
- [Man 3] Like
when shit hits the fan
your bank accounts are negative,
it's your third failure,
right like what do you do?
So we hold on to
the optimism right?
And that comes
from mental strength.
- 100%.
Especially when
your optimism is blind
and doesn't have
practicality wired into it.
- [Man 3] So my question for you
is, if you are an entrepreneur
and it's in your DNA
and you listen to your
intuition and
that's what gives you your
optimism, how do
you, how do you create
the difference between
mental strength as the source
or intuition as the source?
- You have to make
sure that your intuition
is speaking not your delusion.
Right? That's the key
and by the way they're
kissing cousins.
(audience laughter)
- [Man 3] Yeah.
- [Gary] So here's
what I would say,
I would say that in my delusion
I'm an athlete, right?
Like I want to be,
I've got competitive spirit,
I'm a good team
captain type, there's a lot
of things there, but
going onto the playing field
I'm going to consistently
lose at the highest
levels and can't
make a living doing it.
So here's what I would say.
I don't want you, at 23?
First of all, at 23
you're golden, right?
You're golden
because you could literally
do nothing right
for the next seven years
and still be young as fuck.
(audience laughter)
The only piece of
advice I'm gonna give you
is do not collect debt.
And so if you have already,
and you have credit card debt
or what have you,
do you or don't you?
- [Man 3] I mean, minimal.
(audience laughter)
AR is above debt,
so it balances out.
- Get rid of that.
Go work at fucking
7-Eleven, I don't give a fuck.
Get rid of that.
Get rid of that, never
buy another thing in your life
and live with nine dudes,
and do your entrepreneurial
thing for the next decade.
- [Man 3] Cool, thanks Gary.
(audience applause)
- [Man 4] How you doin' Gary?
- Really good.
- [Man 4] Excited to
see you man, I watch
your videos all the time.
- Thank you.
- [Man 4] I have a
brand called Next to Get,
Next to Get's all
about taking action.
You can't be Next to
Get unless you take action.
So I know you love the Jets.
- I do.
- [Man 4] So I got
you a shirt that says,
"Next to Get the New York Jets."
- I love it, and I'll wear it.
Give it to me.
(audience applause)
- One more question though.
- Go ahead.
Go up there, make
sure they hear you.
Thank you my man.
- [Man 4] So I know you
say when you get the Jets
that's gonna be the
worst day of your life.
But it actually
should be one of the best,
because then
you gotta figure out
how to get them in--
- Win The Super Bowl
- [Man 4] The Super Bowl,
exactly.
- I agree. Look, I think that
the reason I say that
is A, there's a
little truth to it,
I think for me, no
question one of the reasons
I think that I'll be successful,
it's really funny that
you asked this question
prior to the
advice that I just gave.
For me, it sounds exciting,
to be 23, have no money,
live in a basement
for seven years,
and try to do your thing.
I genuinely like that,
because I love the game.
Right? I love the game, and so
to me that's what a
true-bred entrepreneur is.
Which is, it has
zero to do with the stuff,
it has to do with the game.
And so, this game
that I made up for myself
somewhere around
fourth grade to buy them
has been the
narrative and the background
for me the whole time,
and so there's a little bit
of that going away.
But at the same token,
the reason I talk about it is,
I don't want
people to get confused.
I want them to
realize that if you
fall in love with the journey,
that is the
ultimate gift in our lives.
Because that's happiness, right?
We're spending so
much time at work.
When you actually get
practical and look at the data,
the amount of time
that you will all spend
in your careers as
a percentage to your
overall time on earth
is extraordinarily high.
So it's super important
to make that something
about more than dollars,
if you're unhappy.
If you're neutral and
the money's there, awesome.
I'm just scared of people
that complain, that's all.
I would tell you
that 98% of my advice
is for people that complain.
Why in the world would I have
advice for you if you're good?
Like, you're good.
- [Man 4] One more
thing I have to ask is,
I would love to be
able to meet with you
and maybe you
could become a mentor
or a business partner.
I know you can help me grow.
- There's no shot.
- [Man 4] I gotta ask.
Gotta ask.
- [Gary] Gotta ask.
I just don't
have that bandwidth.
Like that dude that got lucky
and got the first thing,
and was gonna
come to visit Vayner,
I'll see him for 4.8 seconds.
- [Man 4] That's aight.
- And it might
turn into 19 minutes,
or it might
turn into four hours,
but I never want
to bullshit somebody.
One thing I don't have is time.
Time is everything.
It's why the mobile
device is so important.
It's saving you time.
Time is--
- [Man 4] Check me out
at Next to Get. Check me out.
- I will.
(audience applause)
- [Man 5] Yo, Gary.
How are you feeling today?
- Phenomenal.
- [Man 5] That's great to hear.
It's awesome
just talking to you.
I've been following your
content for the last year or so,
and you taught me
what hustle really was.
I thought I was working,
I've owned my business
for the last four years,
I'm 20 years old now.
So I started speaking
on teen suicide prevention
when I was 16,
- Love it.
After some experience
I went through, and
right now I'm
really growing my media,
and I'm really focusing
on being a media company,
so I started podcasting,
and the question I have is
with daily vlogging.
- [Gary] Yes.
- This might also,
DRock might jump in,
but I'm logistically
thinking of daily vlogging
and what's the
process of your daily vlog
getting up on YouTube?
Do you post it the
day after you film it?
Is it the next week?
- We've done a bunch of stuff.
I think the
first couple of weeks,
it took us like three days,
then we went through
a long period of
doing it the next day,
and now we're
on a two day delay,
even though we have more people.
DRock went through a
hard-core year of filming
the whole thing and then having
to edit it and get it
out there the next day.
I think you can do anything.
You can't cripple yourself.
My buddy Casey stopped
vlogging, so the next day
I was like, "I'm gonna
vlog everyday to pick up
"the thing," but
then literally in my vlog
yesterday, I was like,
"You know the summer's
"coming, I feel like I
need a little more time
"with my family
and don't want to be
"thinking about
producing content,
"so maybe I won't."
I think it's about
reverse-engineering
what you can get done.
And for me,
only two years ago,
three years ago,
there was three people
on my team making content.
It took me four years
to build up VaynerMedia
to have one person
work with me on my content.
Prior to that, it was just me,
and now I'm at 15.
I mean you build.
You build and you
do different things,
and so, I think the process
is as fast as you fucking can.
- [Man 5] Okay, so do
you think a daily vlog
is valuable enough
over something like sales?
'Cause I do a lot of
sales to high schools,
colleges, conferences.
- [Gary] This is the classic
branding versus sales, right?
- [Man 5] Right.
- I think you need to sell
at the most minimum
to make you whole
for whatever you
need to pay your bills. Right?
And then invest
as much as you can
in building your brand.
- [Man 5] So media
comes after sales,
you would recommend?
- [Gary] You gotta pay
your fucking bills, bro.
- [Man 5] Exactly.
(audience laughter)
Well right now
I'm living at home.
- Well then
you're fucking smart.
(audience laughter)
So, to me now it
just becomes a question of
how much money you want.
My big recommendation is,
listen, I only give
advice that I took myself.
I'm a big fan of that.
I took over my
family liquor store business
and I grew if from a three,
at this window
that I'm talking about,
from a three to a
$45 million business
in my early 20's. Right?
I'm 27 years old.
I built a $45 million business,
and I was paying
myself $37,000 a year.
But, I wasn't the typical
dude that needed money
as a leverage to get girls.
- [Man 5] Exactly,
and I don't need
a lot of money right
now, so I'm wondering
whether to build
myself up as a speaker,
without really worrying
about the sales aspect of it?
- Of course.
- [Man 5] Alright, and
as you say that I think,
"That's what
GaryVee would say."
I hear your voice
in my head sometimes,
and I think
GaryVee would say that.
(audience laughter)
Sometimes I dream
about you answering my,
actually I had a
question earlier,
last night I dreamed
about you answering my question.
So, your content
is so effective.
- Now, off of that little story,
watch what I'm doing,
not what I'm saying.
- [Man 5] Yes, yes.
- Got it?
- [Man 5] Got it.
Thank you so much.
(audience applause)
- How much time left?
20?
Good, 20.
- [Woman] Hi GaryVee.
First I want to say thank you,
everything, all
of your podcasts,
all of your videos on YouTube
are kind of my real education.
College was just the paperwork.
I am a marketing manager for
a non-profit organization,
which is a unique position that
I'm very fortunate to have.
Now part of my job,
and it's a new job,
is I'm building up our
presence on social media.
I have three
different target audiences.
I have the women we
serve, the volunteers,
and donors.
- Yep.
- [Woman] My question to
you is does it make sense
to use one platform,
or each platform--
- But one account?
- [Woman] Right, one
account to target all three?
- Yes.
- [Woman] Okay,
instead of focusing on one
platform per group?
- Yes, because the
way we consume content
in social is not binary.
The content finds
who it needs to find.
It's not email 1996,
where people open
up 90% of their email.
- [Woman] Got It.
- It's just one feed.
We don't even know who
the fuck it's coming from.
- You're looking at the content,
not the little logo
that's delivering it.
Got it?
- [Woman] Yes, thank you.
- You're welcome.
(audience applause)
- [John] Hi Gary, my
name is John, first of all,
it's a dream come true, six
months ago, I wrote it down.
I'm gonna meet Gary Vaynerchuk
and here I am right now.
- Good shit bro.
- [John] It's awesome
and then I met Danny Morel.
Wanna thank Danny real quick
for having that vision and
clarity for making it happen.
(audience applause)
I went into real estate so,
what's up guys?
(audience cheers)
It's actually my
first week in real estate
and I'm super excited,
I'm door knocking.
My question is--
- What were you doing last week?
- [John] What's that?
- [John] I was calling and
door knocking and hustling.
- Love it.
- [John] And I'm doing
Facebook Live, I'm doing videos,
all the stuff.
But my question is,
when your parents is saying
when you bring the clients
or talk about the clients
that, oh you don't know
what you're talking about,
oh you have to make sure
all this stuff is correct,
oh what if it you
embarrass yourself,
what would you say to that?
- Well I would say
your parents are probably
right a lot more
than you realize.
- [John] Right.
- If I was in real
estate for the first week--
- [John] Right.
(audience laughter)
- what I would probably do,
so like I'm now actually
super interested in watching
one of your
Facebook Lives because
(audience laughter)
because what
I'm curious about is
are you faking
it 'til you make it
or are you
documenting the journey
of a young man trying
to learn the industry?
My intuition is
number one.
(audience laughter)
What I would do,
if I was in week one,
how many, what
team were you on again?
Let me see all the
people that wooed again.
(audience cheers)
Me, if I was standing
there, I would straddle up
real close to all
those wooing people
and spend one year shutting
the fuck up and listening.
(audience applause and laughter)
'Cause then you'll learn.
You'll taste, then
you'll know what to say.
You're not gonna lose
your charisma and showmanship.
You're a baby,
you just don't know
what the fuck you're
talking about yet.
(audience laughter)
- [John] I have a
follow up question,
should I keep
doing Instagram stories,
just documenting and--
- Dude I think it's
far more interesting,
it was the advice
I gave the other young man,
tell your truth.
You may lose a lot
of people, who are like,
I'm not going with this dude
on his third week.
(audience laughter)
But if you're
actually running a marathon,
in six years, you
could have everybody
who's buying their first house.
(audience applause)
- [John] Thanks Gary,
appreciate it.
- I think you know, now I'm
gonna pander to the crowd,
how many people over 40?
Right so the thing that I think
is super interesting for me,
for everybody that
just raised your hands,
nothing's changed.
Technology is not
gonna allow bad things
to all of a sudden populate.
Right, like, tried and
true is tried and true.
All that technology is
doing is exposing things.
You guys haven't changed
because of all this technology.
You've just been exposed.
- [Man 6] Hey Gary, thank you so
much for being here and Danny
I'm really excited.
I saw a video
that you're doing the
other day about success
and that somebody
who's entrepreneur and makes
$150,000 that's a
lot higher form of success
than some who's 9 to 5
not doing what they want.
- If they're happy.
- [Man 6] Yeah if they're happy.
- It's not about being
a job or an entrepreneur,
my trading desk is unhappiness.
My point there was, if
you're making 150,000 a year
at being a lawyer
and you're not pumped
or you could be
making 98,000 a year
selling slime on
Instagram, but it's your dream
'cause you love making slime
with your eight year old.
I think it's a
worthwhile debate.
I'm just blown away by people
that are literally willing
to binaurally be
dramatically less happy
for an extra $8,000.
So they can go on
a fucking cruise bro.
(audience laughter)
- [Man 6] So my question was,
based on that delineation there
how should people be
thinking about their success?
You also talk about
natural born entrepreneurs
like as much as you
would wanna be LeBron
that takes a certain
amount of natural talent.
So what can you
speak about success
and the role that
patience plays in that?
- So instead of that,
what are you asking me?
What's your situation?
- [Man 6] My situation is
I'm new, I'm listening to
everything that you're saying
days sometimes don't
go well so I'm like okay,
I'm gonna turn on GaryVee
see what he has to say,
try to get some golden
nuggets and I wanna know
a big thing that you
talk about is patience.
And that role that
that plays when you're young
and you're starting and
so I wanted to kinda hear
what you say so I can
kinda like put that in.
- Who are playing this game for
is super interesting for me.
So one of the tough things
that a lot of young people
in this room have,
is they've got
chips on their shoulder.
Because they wanna
prove their mom wrong.
prove that their older sister
isn't the only
star in the family.
You know, where I'm going
with this is, very simply,
almost everybody in this
room, is living their lives
to the judge and jury of
somebody outside of themselves.
And that fuckin blows.
And so where I'm
going with you is
there's a lot of
questions I'd like to ask
but the first one is,
for what and for who?
The reason I win,
you know, there's a scene
it's really funny
'cause I was born in Russia
in the former Soviet Union,
there's a scene in Rocky IV
where Drago loses at the end
but he takes the mic
and he's like fuck you,
he talks in Russian,
I understood it.
He was basically
saying fuck you Russia
that wanted me to
beat this America,
I was fighting for myself.
I was in this ring for myself.
The reason I'm
winning young man,
it's cause I'm in
this ring for myself.
I don't give a fuck what
anybody says about me, nobody.
(audience cheers and applause)
Now,
that, that,
that is a bless
that has nothing to do with me.
That has to do with
my DNA, compounded by
extremely strong parenting
and environment, right.
So I don't say that as I'm
cool, I'm telling you my truth.
And I'm trying to
get as many people
as close to that
as possible because,
I don't have the answers for
you, but what I can tell you is
if you do it for yourself,
if you're judging yourself,
shit gets real easy.
Mine's at zero bad days because
I'm in that binary
place of knowing my intent
and doing what I do,
and then the only
thing that can drag me down
is outside forces around the
health of my family and friends
and luckily for me, the
far majority of those days
aren't gonna be the critical
days where I lose some of them,
right?
That's it, man, like
what are you trying to do?
Is it about the
money, is it about proving
something to somebody?
Because if you're
trying to prove it to yourself,
you have your
whole life to do that.
You have your
Guys, life.
Now as a lot of you
know I love football,
let's call it 80 years,
it's getting better,
even closer to 90.
Just break them
down in four quarters.
Like do you really,
this is why I hate
flashy 25 year old
young entrepreneurs,
do you really want to
be up 21-nothing in the
second quarter and lose 37-28?
(audience laughter)
Because you're
sure acting like it.
So that's what
I'm intrigued by, bro.
- [Man 6] So what am I,
are you asking me the question?
(audience laughter)
I'm confused, man.
- I'm asking you
to figure out who...
Yeah, go ahead.
- Last question,
I do a video every day,
30 seconds or less,
with people and their
favorite quotes.
Can I do one with
you before we leave?
- Yep.
- [Man 6] Alright, thank you.
(audience applause)
- [Woman 2] Can I
give you my card?
- Sure.
Hi, thank you so much,
nice to meet you.
DIdn't realize I was
coming to Right Hook Con.
(audience laughter and applause)
Go ahead.
- [Woman 2] So
I'm not a real estate agent.
I own my own
clothing company, my company
turned five yesterday, so...
- Congrats.
- [Woman 2] Thank you.
We're a wholesale company
and my target audience
actually is women over 40.
- Okay.
- [Woman 3] Yeah!
- [Woman 2] And we do...
- Yeah!
I'm a female over 40,
motherfuckers!
(audience laughter)
- [Woman 2] So
we're wholesale and we sell
to a bunch of different stores.
We are very
successful in wholesale.
- [Gary] Are you doing
direct consumer yet?
- [Woman 2] We
have a very small part
of our business,
only about 5%
of our business
that's sold dot-com.
- [Gary] Are you
trying to grow that?
- [Woman 2] Yes, our challeng is
our demographic, buying online.
I know Snapchat and
Instagram and Facebook,
the younger generation,
they buy online,
that's not the problem--
- You know you're
out of your mind, right?
Like, completely.
- [Woman 2] Well,
we've done surveys,
we've asked our customers--
- Fuck your surveys.
(audience laughter)
- [Woman 2] I'm trying to
figure out what
the best platform
is for my age range.
- Facebook.
- [Woman 2] And converting
that to a Facebook store.
- No, drive them
to your dot-com.
Do you know how much
fashion is sold to 40 to
60 year old women in
e-commerce in this country?
- [Woman 2] A lot. (laughs)
- Okay, because you
just told me your demo
is not doing that,
do you know what I mean?
You might not
know how to do that.
- [Woman 2] That's my challenge,
I don't know how--
- No shit.
(audience laughter)
- [Woman 2] On the
wholesale side, yes,
we know that part, but
on the retail end of it
it's just trying to
figure out what best
avenues to--
- You need to
invest your money into
bringing somebody who has a
dot-com, direct to consumer,
fashion female
background, and let her or him
be your director of
e-com, direct to consumer
and go do your thing.
You're making it
convenient to your
strengths and weaknesses,
which is the quickest way
to go out of business.
I think you know
that, I can tell,
so I don't know your
business, but I would
make a little less
money and immediately hire
somebody who can flat
out and call references,
go hire somebody who's
sold to that lovely lady
on the internet,
you know, and hire them
and then when you hire
them, don't go, okay, great,
I got Ricky or Sally
and go do your thing.
You get real fucking
close and you siphon
that information
out because it's your
fucking company
and you don't want that
to grow to 38% of your business
and then Rick's got
all the fucking leverage.
- [Woman 2] Right.
(audience applause)
- [Man 7] Last question,
guys, last question.
- Sorry everybody in line.
- [Man 7] Sorry.
- He's a real dick.
(audience laughter)
- [Dallas] Hey,
my name's Dallas, sir.
Thank you for the motivation.
I look up to you
because I'm also an immigrant
and you give me a good example
that success can
actually be reached no matter
where you come
from, so thank you.
- Dude, immigrants
have the advantage.
(audience cheer and applause)
They really do, and by
the way, American born people
dominate, but the advantage
is we know the alternative.
My kids are
fucking going to be losers.
(audience laughter)
Like, you know, it's
just hard when you got it
and don't work
for it, so I'm glad
that's the case, but
I want you to realize
how good of an
advantage you actually have.
- [Dallas] Yeah, my
youngest brothers actually
tell me that all the time.
They say, well,
you just work harder
because you're an
immigrant and you have
the immigrant mentality.
- And you should
look them dead in the face
and say, that's
right, motherfucker.
(audience laughter and applause)
- [Dallas] I'm
actually recording it,
so they'll hear it for sure.
- And then also tell them that
you're also working smarter
now what, dick?
(audience laughter)
- [Dallas] It's all right here.
- I hate that fucking argument.
Gary, yeah, it's
cool, you hustle,
but I work smart.
Me too dick face, now what?
(audience laughter)
- [Dallas] Yeah, I do both.
So here's my situation.
I recently started
a business on my own.
- Good for you.
- [Dallas] Thank you.
And so it's being
going pretty well.
It's a retail business,
it's a brick and mortar
business, and I know
that you actually talk about
how brick and
mortars are possibly going
out of business soon.
- If their economics
are too tied into
unrealistic leases and
they don't have alternatives.
- Right, so,
remember how I said,
everything in media can work,
it's what's
underpriced and overpriced.
Retail is not gonna die, people.
It's just retailers
are not gonna pay $87
a square foot when
the way we buy now,
it should be 61, got it?
- [Dallas] Got it.
- And, instead of spending
their money on fixtures,
they may allocate
25% of their space
for you to drink coffee,
or for a band to be there,
they're gonna have to change,
this is all about change.
So, that's what's
on my mind, keep going.
- [Dallas] So, my thing is,
I have an opportunity now
because the
business is doing well,
to expand into
a second location,
which is also a
brick and mortar,
but my dilemma--
- Let me give you
- a good piece of advice.
- [Dallas] Yeah.
- Whatever projections you have,
or whatever your
business is currently doing,
just siphon out 20% of it,
just make pretend
you lost 20% of it,
and if the math works,
then go for it.
- [Dallas] Okay.
- Got it?
- [Dallas] Got it.
- Just anticipate the decline.
- [Dallas] The 20% decline,
is that over--
- That's my intuition
that the microeconomic climates
of what retail is doing,
will affect you.
You may not even ever feel that,
you may feel 50% of it,
but you can't be blunt,
well what do you sell?
- [Dallas] I sell
fitness supplements.
- Yeah, fuck, man.
(audience laughter)
People buy that shit
at scale on the internet,
so don't get fucking
crazy, keep that in mind.
- [Dallas] Yeah, so I sell
this stuff online as well,
so my question was,
whether I should take the
second brick-and-mortar store
and continue
doing business online,
or if I should just
take that full lump of money
that I would invest into
a brick-and-mortar store,
which got me here
in the first place,
and just take it all and
invest it in my e-commerce.
- What gets you
somewhere is irrelevant
to where you're going.
(audience applause)
- Got it?
- [Dallas] Perfect.
- So, I think
you know the answer,
we don't need to pay homage
to that fucking
store that got you there.
- [Dallas] Gotcha, okay.
And then this
other question too,
is kind of interesting--
- [Man 7] No, no,
no, no, no, that's it.
It's not fair to
- I told you--
- everybody else.
- he was a dick!
(audience laughter)
- [Dallas] Alright,
well, thank you.
- Thank you.
- [Man 7] You
know what, gold digger,
'cause I like
that, one more, go.
- [Dallas] Thank you.
Is it alright if
I get a picture?
- That's it.
With you, Gary?
You helped me realize
that I needed to quit my job
selling cars so I can actually
go into business for myself,
so I'd like to
thank you for that,
and I'd really like
- Come.
a picture with you.
- This way, she can
- escort you up.
- You can come up and
you can ask, go ahead.
Oh, you're taking
a picture, got it.
(audience applause)
Nice to meet
you, man, good luck.
- [Woman 3] Hi, hi Gary,
oh my gosh.
I came down here
from Northern California
just to say thank you for
all the content you put out,
because I found you when I was
at a really
tumultuous part of my life,
and my life just,
being fully accountable,
and just not
going for perfect...
just getting it done and
just making micro-adjustments
has just quantifiably
made my life so much better,
and I just
wanted to say thank you.
- You're welcome.
(audience applause)
- [Woman 3] Can I
take a selfie, too?
- I like your skirt.
- Oh, thank you (inaudible).
(audience laughter)
Thank you so much.
- Awesome.
- Awesome, give Gary
a round of applause, everybody!
(audience applause and cheers)
- Thank you so much.
- So, hold on,
I gotta tell you
guys a little story,
you know, it was
kind of awesome because...
last night, I highly
respect this guy,
and I'm gonna tell you why,
because I had this illusion
that, I know he
says he works hard,
but I didn't really
understand how hard he works,
so I'm thinking if
I'm gonna do an event,
I'm gonna fly in
the night before,
relax, hang out
for a little bit,
wake up the next day,
maybe I'll do a little workout,
you know what I'm saying?
- Yep.
- And maybe do
some work in the room,
and then when it's
time for me to speak,
then, I come up and speak, you
know, that's normal, right?
Well, last night, I noticed
on his Instagram story,
I'm like, fuck, he's
not on an airplane yet!
(audience laughter)
And then this
morning, I'm stressing,
I was like, the
money went through, right,
(Gary laughter)
'cause it was a
lot of money, right?
And I'm stressing,
I'm watching DRock,
and I'm watching Gary,
and I'm watching both of them
and they're still not on their
way to the airport, right?
And then it was
literally like 10 o'clock A.M.,
and I finally see you guys
on your way to the airport.
I get offstage and the
dudes are literally walking in
from taking maybe a
three minute shower,
we sit down on our podcast
and you know, afterwards,
we're just kind
of shooting the shit,
and the podcast is done, which
went fantastic, by the way,
and I go, so what's up, what
are you guys doing after?
But, I'm ready to
invite him to my house,
to come barbecue,
hang out, have a party, relax,
he goes, "Oh, I'm gonna hop
on a plane. I got a red-eye."
Like, the guy
literally woke up this morning,
got on a plane, flew here,
talked for a little bit,
is gonna get on
a plane, and go back,
like, that's legit, people.
(audience applause)
That's legit, so give him a
round of applause for that.
- Thank you.
Take a red-eye,
land in New York,
drive an hour in
New York early morning traffic,
take a quick shower, and
then go do a 11-hour day,
and then hop on a
flight and fly to Ghana.
- Oh.
(audience whistles)
I'm...Pencils of Promise,
I'm part of a non-profit
called Pencils of Promise,
so I'm gonna go
build some schools,
check on what we're doing,
(audience cheers and applause)
- Yeah.
- Thank you.
- Hold on, hold on.
Secondly, I have
to say something.
I wanna take a moment to say
thank you to all of you guys,
because I know GaryVee
represents something different
to each and
every one of you guys,
but for me personally,
what it represents,
is a sign of my
intense commitment to go all-in,
(audience cheers)
to go all-in, right?
And when I say that,
(audience applause)
it's to go all-in in all of you,
and all-in in
our journey together,
and all-in in the growth
that we're about to have,
so I'm gonna commit right
now, he's gonna come back,
I'm gonna, on Monday,
call the agency,
and I'm gonna book
him again for next year.
- DRock, raise the price!
- Yeah? No, no, no.
(audience laughter)
So, I'm gonna do that now,
(Gary laughs)
'cause I know the
price is going up, alright?
Yeah?
- Arbitrage!
And then lastly, if
everybody gets a damn picture,
I want a picture,
- That's a good point
so let's do a
huge selfie, everybody.
Sound good, everybody?
(audience cheers)
- [Gary] Awesome, awesome.
- Give it up for GaryVee!
(audience cheers and applause)
(light electronic music)